lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
ver a profundidad la transcripción y la
manera de repaso vimos esto en el vídeo
de replicación del adn y transcripción y
traducción del arn la palabra
transcripción en el lenguaje cotidiano
significa copiar algo o reescribir
alguna información en otra forma y eso
es esencialmente lo que está pasando
aquí la transcripción ocurre cuando
tomamos la información codificada en un
gen en el adn y codifica mos
esencialmente la misma información en el
arn mensajero o bien a rn m así que en
la transcripción vamos del adn al a rn
mensajero
y en este vídeo nos vamos a centrar en
genes que codifican para proteínas así
que este primer paso es la transcripción
de adn
rn mensajero
y luego en un vídeo futuro vamos a
profundizar un poco más en la traducción
vamos a traducir esa información en una
proteína aquí tenemos estos dibujos que
nos dan una visión general de la
transcripción es un poco más simple en
las bacterias el adn se encuentra
flotando en el sitio sol y la
transcripción se lleva a cabo se empieza
con el adn con un gen que codifica para
una proteína y a partir de éste se
codifica el rn mensajero que es esta
línea morada por aquí y el arn mensajero
se puede asociar con el ribosoma y
ocurre el proceso de traducción para
producir el poli péptido para obtener la
proteína en las células eucariotas y
vamos a ver esto más a fondo en este
vídeo la transcripción el proceso de
pasar del adn
fnm sucede en el interior del núcleo y
ocurre esencialmente en dos pasos se
pasa de adn a lo que llamamos
rn m déjame escribir eso
rn m
es este de aquí y este tiene que ser
procesado para convertirse en lo que
llamamos a efe nm que después salen del
núcleo para ser traducido en una
proteína así que ahora que tenemos este
resumen vamos a profundizar un poco más
en el tema para que comprendamos los
diferentes actores y entendamos el tipo
de procesamiento que ocurre cuando
estamos hablando de una célula eucariota
por aquí vamos a comenzar con un gen
dentro del adn que codifica para alguna
proteína es este de aquí y el actual
principal aquí no es el adn o el adn m
sino que va a ser la arn polimerasa se
usa para crear una secuencia de
nucleótidos que se convertirá en el arn
mensajero y esta arn polimerasa necesita
saber por dónde empezar y la forma en
que sabe por dónde empezar es uniéndose
a una secuencia del adn conocida como
promotor y cada gen va a tener un
promotor asociado a él
sobre todo si estamos hablando de las
células eucariotas a veces es posible
que haya un promotor asociado a una
colección de genes pero en general si se
tiene un gen este va a tener un promotor
y es así como la arn polimerasa sabe que
se tiene que unir justo ahí una vez que
se une puede separar las hebras o las
cadenas de adn y es bastante interesante
porque cuando vimos a fondo la
replicación vimos a todos estos actores
la él y casa entre otras pero esta
enzima el complejo arn polimerasa
separan las hebras y luego codifica para
el arn y lo hace de la misma manera que
cuando estudiamos la adn polimerasa lo
hace en una sola dirección solo puede
añadir más nucleótidos en el extremo 3
prima así que codifica en dirección de 5
prima a 3 prima como puedes ver estas
flechas se encuentran en el extremo 3
prima del arn
y como se puede ver aquí cuando hace
esto solo se está codificando la
información complementaria de una de las
cadenas pero reflexionemos un poco al
respecto la cadena con la que el arnés
está interactuando la podemos llamar la
cadena molde porque es el lado del adn
está actuando como una plantilla para la
formación del arn pero si pensamos en la
información que el arn va a codificar
podemos ver que va a contener la misma
información que la otra cadena de adn
la cadena codificante ya que estos
nucleótidos de aquí este nucleótido va a
ser complementario a este de aquí al
igual que este nucleótido era
complementario a este de aquí y podemos
ver eso aquí con mayor detalle si
añadimos los nucleótidos así que esta es
la cadena molde si tenemos aquí una
timina entonces en el arn tendríamos una
avenida y mira en la cadena codificante
de adn
esta cadena de aquí también tenemos una
avenida esencialmente la cadena
codificante y el arn terminan siendo la
misma secuencia y la única diferencia
entre ellas es que en el arn no se
encuentra la timina en vez de timina se
puede encontrar una base nitrogenada
similar un asilo pero el uras y lo
desempeña el papel de la timina por lo
que esencialmente estamos codificando la
misma información así una vez más esta
cadena inferior está actuando como una
plantilla pero el rn resultante que fue
codificado esencialmente va a tener la
misma información de la cadena
codificante solo para que podamos
apreciar cómo se ve todo esto y pongo la
palabra ver entre comillas ya que es muy
difícil realmente poder ver todo esto
pero se puede apreciar aquí que la
enzima polimerasa y esto es para un
organismo específico puede ser muy muy
compleja y es fascinante como todo esto
interactúen entre sí
cada vez que te encuentras estudiando
biología y alguien como yo te ve estas
explicaciones limpias de cómo estas
enzimas interactúan con las diferentes
macromoléculas como el adn o el adn
debes recordar siempre que esto es
increíble estamos hablando de estas
moléculas que están interactuando entre
sí rebotando unas con otras y todo esto
está sucediendo en el interior de las
células de una manera increíblemente
rápida
deberíamos estar totalmente
impresionados por esto está sucediendo
en todas tus células en este momento
esto es algo bastante increíble muy bien
así que por acá estábamos viendo la
elongación de la cadena de arn y te
puedes preguntar cuándo se va a detener
esto pues bueno esta arn polimerasa va a
seguir avanzando por la cadena hasta que
llegue a esta parte azul a la que
llamamos terminador por lo que esta
parte es un terminado
y hay varias maneras en que señala a la
arn polimerasa que es hora de detenerse
más particularmente crea algo que debido
a su estructura la polimerasa
simplemente tiene que soltar o dejar ir
uno de los mecanismos que está
representado aquí es que el arn que está
codificado y esto podría suceder en las
bacterias es que el inm que está
codificado adopta una estructura en
forma de horquilla por lo tanto tiene
que tener los pares de bases
complementarios adecuados para formar
esta estructura de horquilla y esta
horquilla junto con las cosas que se
encuentran alrededor de la horquilla
impiden que la polimerasa pueda
continuar su avance por lo que el
complejo cambia un poco y así suelta la
cadena o por lo menos eso es lo que se
cree que sucede
hay otras formas en que el terminado
pudiera actuar podría tratarse de
secuencias que algunas partes del
complejo de arn polimerasa reconocen y
generan un cambio en su conformación de
manera que la arn polimerasa se
desprende si estamos hablando de una
célula procariotas entonces ya
terminamos este sería nuestro arn
mensajero que puede ir a un ribosoma y
luego ser traducido en una proteína pero
si estamos hablando de una célula
eucariota entonces tenemos que hacer un
poco de procesamiento si esto fuera una
célula procariotas esto sería nuestro
arne m y si esto es una célula eucariota
entonces esto es nuestro pre a efe nm
que ahora tiene que ser procesado y
podrías preguntar cómo va a ser
procesado bueno hay un par de cosas que
van a ocurrir algunas cosas van a ser
añadidas al inicio y al final del arn
como la cap 5 prima o caperuza 5 prima
esta es una guanina modificada
guanina
modificadas
que va a ayudar en el proceso de
traducción conforme los ribosomas se
unen a ella y por acá tenemos esta cola
poli
y se llama cola poli a porque tiene un
montón de adenina en el extremo estos no
sólo ayudan en el proceso de traducción
sino que ayudan a asegurarse de que la
información sea más resistente que los
extremos del adn m no sufran daños ahora
bien la otra cosa que necesita ser
procesada y esta es una de esas cosas
fascinantes en la biología evolutiva es
que en esta secuencia de adn m hay
partes de la secuencia que actualmente
consideramos como secuencias sin sentido
sí
sentido
y las llamamos intrones y lo puse entre
comillas porque en general en la
evolución es muy raro que las cosas no
tengan absolutamente ningún propósito
pero estos no están codificando para la
proteína que es codificada por nuestro
gen inicial y así estos son eliminados
mediante empalmes y cortes no voy a
entrar en los detalles de los actores
que llevan a cabo estos empalmes y
cortes pero como parte de este
procesamiento que ocurre en las células
eucariotas se agrega la cab sin que
prima se agrega la cola poli a y luego
se eliminan los intrones y una vez que
se han eliminado los intrones todo lo
que queda son los exones por lo que
vamos a tener este que va a estar
conectado a este que va a estar
conectado a este y esto es lo que
obtenemos esto está en una célula
eucariota obtenemos este a efe nm maduro
y eso es lo que tenemos aquí que luego
migra fuera del núcleo a un ribosoma en
el que puede ser traducido